welcome back to my top 10 favorite
comedies well let's not waste any time
let's get back to the countdown number 5
Ghostbusters yeah you knew it was coming
aside from the fact that has an
unbelievably creative premise
Ghostbusters succeeds from having some
of the funniest people at the time in
one place bill murray dan Aykroyd Harold
Ramis
how could go wrong with that trio I just
love the way these guys work off each
other and make a really complete and
funny team on top of that the lines man
the lines are just perfect this is
probably the movie I quote the most in
general situations next to maybe Batman
and actually the next movie you'll see
on the list here the lines are just so
cynical and laid-back that it's hard not
to use them in everyday talk the cool
thing is that when I was a kid I was
only familiar with the cartoon and then
I was like dude there's a movie dude
they swear up a storm dude they're
smoking this is badass and to me they
still are pretty badass they're
comedians with weapons they're
practically my personal heroes I looked
up to it then and I look up to it now I
love the idea I love the jokes but most
of all I love the characters number 4
Spaceballs this is another movie I quote
all the time not as much from the lone
star in vespa story but more from the
dark helmet subplot these guys take up
so much of the movie and to me there's
nothing funnier than a powerful guy who
is an absolute loser
I love being confidence that they
produce whenever Helmut Sanders and
skroob get together it's impossible to
keep a straight face
they just clearly have no idea what
they're doing you're looking at
different levels of idiocy and yet
somehow they have an entire empire at
their command and that just really
cracks me up how did they get an entire
empire at their command and of course
the visual jokes are just a riot
most of them being over-the-top cartoony
and filled with painful slapstick I
quoted a lot in my videos and everyone
always gets the references then even
though the lines and puns are
good it's the characters that keep us
coming back particularly the villains
these guys make me laugh every single
time never without fail what else can I
say but may the Schwartz be with you
number three what's up doc now don't get
me wrong I'm not really a Barbara
Streisand or Ryan O'Neal fan but this
group all comedy has some of the best
writing and fastest timing in maybe the
past 50 years the jokes are quick the
characters are quirky and again it pays
tribute to the epic comedy by having one
hell of a great kart race at the end
it's right up there with the Blues
Brothers chase in terms of creativity
and laugh value it's just perfect the
sort of like a forest what's up doc
takes a lot of its comedy from screwball
films like his girl Friday and bringing
up baby
on top of that as you probably guess it
also takes a lot of a tumor from the
Looney Tunes when you watch it it may
start off a little slow but trust me
when I save you stick with it you're
really in for something clever and
really funny and I never thought I'd
recommend this try same picture but
trust me when I say it's well worth
checking out number two
the Great Race
another great epic comedy in fact it's
sort of like the Lawrence of Arabia of
comedies the scope is huge traveling all
over the world for its locations and yet
it all centers around one simple premise
some a-hole hates another guy's guts and
so he wants to show them up that's it
from that we get car chases sword fights
explosions and probably the mother of
all pie fights it's characters are so
simple and yet so likeable Tony Curtis
plays the great Leslie a daredevil
record breaker and just all-around
perfect guy Natalie Wood plays Miss
Dubois feisty and determined feminists
who will do anything to get her point
across but the scene stealer by far is
Jack Lemmon as Professor fate and if you
want to know where I got a lot of the
nostalgia critic from just watch his
performance that's
that'd be Leslie it will be our
professor fate fate the magnificent
he is so angry so bitter and yet so bad
at hiding it that it's just impossible
not to laugh in it
I love how over-the-top and confident he
is even though he fails every single
time his ego is only surpassed by his
cowardliness and again I think a lot of
that humor comes from the Looney Tunes
particularly Daffy Duck what time my
self draw a lot of inspiration from much
like dark helmet he's what makes the
movie for me but on top of that I just
love how grand it is and how far the
movie will go just to get a few cheap
laughs
it is pretty old-school and I will admit
I don't know if it's for everybody but
I'll admit that I got a lot of
inspiration from it and it definitely
made a huge impact on my sense of humor
and my number one funniest comedy is Hot
Fuzz I know it's weird to put such a
current movie as my favorite comedy but
every time I see it there's always like
a dozen jokes that I miss I just love
how fast blatant subtle direct verbal
and visual these jokes are I think every
joke known to man is try it out in this
movie and they're thrown at you a mile a
minute
I love the pacing I love the story and I
love how it all seems to be building up
to a gigantic punch line which also
serves as the climax for a movie it's so
over-the-top yet there's also a lot of
little jokes happening that you miss the
first time around and even the second
time around I've seen this movie about
five times and I still don't think I've
seen all the jokes they're so fast and
so clever that you have no choice but to
go back and watch it over and over again
thankfully the characters are
well-written enough to support several
viewings as well
they're funny likable and enjoyable to
watch even when they're batshit insane
now unfortunately to talk about it too
much would be giving away a lot of the
jokes and the storylines but I can
easily say that I have never left harder
and more consistently than I have
watching Hot Fuzz the all-time funniest
movie I've ever seen
thanks for watching I hope you enjoyed
my pics PVM in CA of
yet check him out